so I just want to start off talking
about the movie sort of overall cuz it's
such a heavy historic story and I'm
wondering if there's ever a moment a
specific moment maybe in pre-production
or maybe in preparation where the the
weight of it hit you or you sort of felt
the history of the entire thing there
was a big moment for me you know when we
okay so the scene where the big that big
scene and my character has when I'm in
the Eichmann house and I see Klaus his
father you know put him against the wall
and he calls him father and then I leave
and then you run after me
so when we actually did filmed that
scene afterwards when Joe comes up and
he's like I thought you were and I'm
like I am we're how long we waited
around till they actually started
filming and I was kind of just like what
pacing around like trying to stay in the
zone and I like got to this place where
I did feel like a weight I felt like I
don't know if it sounds crazy but I felt
like other spirits and souls from like
70 years ago like I don't know and I
don't know if that sounds totally wacky
but I really did I felt really connected
to the the the purpose of telling the
story so yeah that was cool feeling and
in telling the story it requires you to
really brush up with these this awful
imagery and this and the the
paraphernalia at that time and I'm
wondering if those those very intense
scenes sort of require a sort of detox
once once it says cut like I think of
you I think of you hanging out of the
Nazi flag I don't know if I could do
that's a very intense moment I'm
wondering if you know when the director
says cut or hours afterwards that
requires like not not a cleansing but is
just sort of a a moment I think the one
that was maybe the most affecting
immediately after he said calf was was
maybe for me the rally when when they
will gather early on in the film at the
right-wing rally and just having a room
of a hundred people kind of swimming
with that screaming and then you had to
read like my character obviously is like
completely just shocked and like you
know distraught by it but but you the
way you had to react like that's intense
I'm interviewing ya as two young actors
in in your careers what did you take
away from from maybe just watching Ben
Kingsley work or anything you took away
from from anything he told you anything
you saw him do on set what's the what's
the take away from working with such a
an established iconic actor like Sir Ben
Kingsley I think he was just like he was
so focused all the time and in like the
right mind space and where other people
would understand we be chatting in
between takes and kind of mmm you know
she's actually like doing their own
thing he kind of just would sit in sit
in his own space and be thinking about
what he wanted to do and try and stay in
the right the right zone and to kind of
see him do that was pretty amazing he's
very focused I was very focused anything
you